good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope
everybody had a blessed and sacred
weekend speaking of blessedness and
sacrosicity it's Jax hey Jax hi turdy
Lou Little Turtle
little it's Turtle time
Turtle time hey clerdial how are you
doing
you know what I'm doing okay I had a
bout of food poisoning last night I
believe that's what it was I don't
really want to get into it but it was
giving notovirus Circa 2021
um I am triggered I am traumatized I'm
like still deeply unwell but I'm much
better and I'm feeling grateful that
you're on bed rest so that we don't have
to go into the studio today we're both
podcasting from home and honestly I
wouldn't have it any other way I'm in no
shape to be leaving the house so what I
should be saying is yeah welcome
pretty much pretty much that's what you
should be saying what can I say except
yeah welcome
it's so great to be back on the mic on
the ones and the twos with Jax you know
yeah it is I missed you we podcasted on
Thursday but then Friday your big
episode with Jack strapped that's why it
feels like it's been so long turdy Lou
Making Waves making headlines
all right everyone what did you think
about the Jax episode I thought it was
quite redeeming you know Jax like he he
talks a lot and you know we kind of kind
of have that in common you know we like
to cut each other off and and I was
really kind of you know mindful to be
measured and and speak when spoken to
because it wasn't about me um and I
think I did a good job of like not um
speaking over him while he was speaking
over me you know yeah no it was good but
you're also just like friends so it
doesn't have to be like 60 Minutes it
could be more of a conversation and also
that's what a podcast is
and I was really excited because you
were just podcasting because the AV
Queen in me was so excited that we got
to use our new third camera I don't know
if you guys noticed on YouTube we had
not one not two but three angles and it
was really exciting to be able to test
that out which acts and I think I think
it turned out swimmingly but you didn't
use your new AI
no no and I don't want people knowing
that I'm using AI don't share that with
them okay sorry uh turdy doesn't use Ai
No no no no no no no no I don't
definitely don't use AI software to edit
someone a while ago made some Tick Tock
videos of my voice using AI you had sent
them to me they were so funny and I
rewatched them recently because I was
just like telling Zach because we were
talking about Ai and he was like don't
you worry that the toast could be
replaced by AI I was like no I've seen a
script and it's really terrible so
that's fine yeah they actually did there
were these videos that recreated my
voice and like said stuff that I would
say and now I can't get it out of my
head like okay but it did not sound like
you it did a little bit upon re-watching
and then also like I guess the person
who made The Tick Tock wrote the script
and they know how I speak because it was
like right no that's turdy's book I
can't sign that come on bro Mommy needs
a drink but yeah that's me yeah but
that's not AI because there was a human
being behind it
you can't take the humanity out of the
toast and that's why I sleep well
knowing AI is not coming for my job I do
sleep well like on that front you know
but I also was warm and I need to get a
pregnancy pillow and yeah I'm not
sleeping like that well I actually I
didn't sleep that well either because of
the food poisoning but just know the
food poisoning was keeping me up and not
the future of AI yeah no just no it was
like whether or not to buy a pregnancy
pillow and if so which one would I buy
was keeping me up I just feel like the
one on Amazon like the one that comes up
suggested is good enough that's what I
bought last time
too big and not helpful enough for how
much space it takes up then I got a
different one that's by like boppy it's
just like two balls that it's actually
much better but I feel like I could do
even better this time knowing all right
put it out there see what the toasters
recommend yeah I got like a Facebook ad
for one yesterday that looked really
scrumptious
Facebook ads are so effective it's
disgusting yeah they really are we share
a Facebook so I get like a lot of kids
stuff which I get does all Taylor Swift
videos all the time oh really all tell
like I know everything about her and
everything that goes on in her concerts
that's so funny that like you're getting
my targeted information and I'm getting
your targeted information I know why
can't they figure out figure it out like
based on device it's not that word Mark
Mark they do better so smart but they
just miss the mark
yes yes they did yes they did so we've
got a great show we've got stories we
have so much TV to recap because
Jackie's been on her bed rest grind with
her new television from Costco that we
bought on instacart and she's kind of
she's putting in the work she's
retroactively recapping everything yeah
so I'm all cut up on Real Housewives of
New Jersey from last week this weekend I
got all caught up on summer house I
watched the whole season and the whole
reading and it was only two parts and I
am just shocked by the way that I feel
and how it's so out of step with The
Narrative of the show yeah and out of
step with Andy did you watch both
reunions yes Andy like took aside and
took a stand
and I just like I can't believe how
how opposite I feel but I'll save it for
the TV recap but that was just really
shocking to me and the TV recap I also
watched the fourth and final season of
never have I ever which is just like a
show for teenagers that I'm obsessed
with Ben is even more in love with it
than I am so I'm gonna save that for the
TV recap too but highly recommend it's a
great bad Rush show it's like short
episodes it's funny it's light it's cute
it really gives a deep respect and
admiration for Indian culture as well
thanks for the recommendation I'll add
it to the list though I'm going through
my list really slowly
because I don't have like that much time
to watch TV and then at night I watch
with Zach so we have like our together
show we're watching Love and Death and
we watch the third episode and he fell
asleep for the whole thing so now we're
kind of at a Crossroads we're at a
Crossroads like do you move on without
him or now you have to re-watch the
third episode should we re-watch it
together
do I just fill him in and we could
forage ahead
or do we go our separate ways the thing
is it's like it's only a seven episode
series so there's not like a lot of
fodder like every episode like needs to
be watched and it's good and he should I
felt like that episode actually like I
could just tell you what
getting us to a place where now things
are going to pop off
you know like the show starts really on
episode four like the whole thing but
but I don't know context is important
but he like doesn't pay that close
attention like he always is okay so just
move on he's always on his phone like
he's not like me like if I didn't hear
something I will rewind yeah me too me
too
all right so maybe just move on
otherwise we're gonna be stuck on
episode three forever and maybe it's
important for Zach to learn you know the
consequences of his actions you fall
asleep you miss stuff
yeah yeah at least say you're going to
sleep and I'll watch summer house oh
that is so Ben like we're watching
something and I could feel his presence
like shutting down I'm like are you
going to sleep like just tell me I'll
turn the TV off we can go to bed
together like he's like no no I'm just
resting my eyes like always resting his
eyes and I'm like no you're not and it's
one of my biggest pet peeves like I hate
being awake by myself so if Ben's going
to sleep like I will go to sleep go to
sleep
go to sleep yeah
so it's like one of my biggest pet
peeves that's so annoying well speaking
of going to sleep it's like been taking
me a while to fall asleep these days
because I'm just so uncomfortable so I
started a new book last night the
Senator's wife by Liv Constantine have
you read anything by her I have you have
what has she written us they're all you
know like
this is the last time I saw you with the
red necklace the red book with the
necklace on the cover yes yes you
recommend it I loved that book okay so
I'll let you know about this one um okay
I'm like 20 it's good and also in some
other book news yeah by the way I want
to clear up some rumors going around
about us because I got so many messages
about this what's the rumor the room
okay so a lot of people saw critically
acclaimed Australian Queen author Sally
Hepworth yesterday revealed the cover
and title of her new book she sent it
out I think in her newsletter and she um
gave like a little synopsis about what
the book is about and you know the
toasters were immediately put on alert
because the book is about three sisters
named Claudia Jackie and Margo and
everyone was like oh my God oh my God oh
my God and I posted it on my story I'm
like not us being you know the
inspiration for these titles these the
names of these characters and so many
people were messaging me like oh my God
what a crazy coincidence like is this
intentional and yeah it's intentional
like Sally reached out to me she was
like I'm gonna name
um
some characters after you and Jackie is
Jackie's full name Jacqueline and I was
like yes but like you can do Jackie or
Jackie my full name is Claudia and we
were like we've known about this for
like a while like maybe a year and we
were like freaking out and then a few
months later she was like wait I think
I'm gonna do three sisters now
um what are your other sisters names and
I was like Olivia and Margo and she
chose Margot and Margo's like a big
reader so Margo's relics and Margo love
Sally have worth Margo's like so excited
I don't even know if Olivia would have
cared like if she got named after
because she doesn't read but I wanted to
clear up that this wasn't some sort of
cool Winky Dink or like we knew we've
been known we've been in the know no
it's as cool as it sounds like it's yeah
like an accidentally cool thing that
happened like it it was intentional and
Sally chose us to be her sisters I just
hope that they're good scenes you know I
actually I think that they're like kind
of mischievous like girlies but Sally
always the last Sally Hepworth book I
wrote um like the crazy girl her name
was Heather and she wrote on the you
know before the title page it's like a
disclaimer that she did it uh contest on
her Instagram and people in the charity
auction yeah and the person who won got
to be like the name so she was like
while Heather is horrible Heather in
real life is actually amazing and these
two characters are not you know even
really similar but they just share a
name so I do believe we'll be getting
our own page like that too hopefully oh
hopefully yeah she's always like just
wheeling and dealing names of names of
characters in her book I guess when you
write so many books with so many
characters it's like yeah you can start
just naming them after people you love
no totally and I'm honored I cannot wait
to read this book it's one of the most
exciting things that's ever happened to
us I know and because Sally Hepworth is
like one probably top three author of
mine same period I just finished the
soulmate which I love like she has never
flopped so like to know that there's a
book that's Loosely inspired by our
beings no and that I don't think it's by
the way I don't think it's even remotely
inspired by us that's why I said Loosely
inspired by our beings but it's not like
it has it's just like just even if it's
just a name it's extremely loose
but no we're not inspired like I feel
like Sally makes that really clear like
I feel like I know Sally you know no I
know that like there's not gonna be two
that do a podcast and one with red hair
like I know that oh my God I would love
if they were podcasters but that's the
thing like the characters have nothing
to do besides our names they're Loosely
inspired by our beings or and that just
means our name okay yeah okay but like
in case it one of them turns out to be
like a murderer or something like that's
not us we don't murder okay I don't
whatever I'm flattered the end no I'm
gaffade beyond be I'm awestruck yeah
when does it come out I think October
yeah and um I still haven't read her
recent book The soulmate because it's my
select for book club and um my selection
is not up for like another month or two
so I have a long way I have to weigh it
who
over maybe you should be like you know
my God I feel like actually like I think
there's like two more people like I
might be October but no it's only June I
don't know I can also ask to be moved
like the group is very flexible we
actually had to swap this month Natalie
for Michelle just because of like some
scheduling conflicts I think I'm October
for the redheads
I think you should choose it I think
also because Sally Hepworth is like a
safe choice for a book club her books
have never been bad and it's always like
a really good thriller and a thriller's
always gonna like keep a book club back
you know keep them in good spirits yeah
and I think by then we'll be ready for
another Thriller like because we're all
trying to do something different with
like these most recent choices because
we were reading like the same book over
and over again but by then like I'll be
back to
Thriller well you know what it is it's
thrilling it is thrilling
it's a thrill tis a thrill are you
reading anything no I like I haven't
been able to pick up my Kindle you know
what I mean like I read like four books
in one week like two weeks ago yeah and
I'm just like I'm on a break you know I
haven't even I have no urge to reach for
my Kindle and I'm just leaning in my
break just ended my watch has ended and
you know what I'll have to pick pick up
my Kindle for my book club anyway so
I'll probably then get back into it
that's what's so great about a book club
like you're you can't ever break for
that long yeah like the max you can do
is like a month yeah it keeps you
accountable yeah I love that
um before we dive in I wanted to tell
everyone about
um just kind of like the craziest thing
that happened to me too actually there's
two Monumental things that happened to
me this weekend does one of them have to
do with your forehead uh one of them
does have to do with my forehead I
feel like everybody knows this because I
posted on Instagram but in case you
listen to this podcast and don't have an
Instagram in which case how did you find
us
um I have been walking around with the
biggest [__] like bruise slash hickey
slash circle of popped blood vessels
right at the center of my forehead it
couldn't be bigger it couldn't be more
omnipresent it couldn't be more like
centered on my face and it won't go away
it was an anti-related injury and the
amount of people mothers fathers parents
Aunts Uncles who messaged me saying oh
my God the same thing happened to me is
absurd like how did I not know that this
was a thing I was at Jackie's house what
day was this Friday
I guess so yeah we were doing makeup in
bed and stuff oh yeah and you know
obviously Harry climbed into bed with us
and it was amazing and we had a bunch of
toys on the bed and he had some of his
their bath toys correct yeah they were
bath toys that that hadn't made it to
the bath yet they were like a new right
unboxed unboxing and they're cool
because they're like little fidget
Spinners but they suction to the bathtub
so when Harry is you know getting his
ass washed somebody can you know get to
business and Harry can just fiddle with
his with his toys and not be bothered
and I was like oh how cute suction and I
was like I wonder if this will suction
to my forehead and it did and then I was
like making it spin and Harry I mean he
wasn't like he didn't think it was like
the funniest best thing ever but I got
like a little bit of a chuckle like
nothing crazy laugh yeah yeah at least
it wasn't at least at least I didn't get
nothing you know imagine if I had this
big thing on my forehead and he didn't
even laugh no he smiled he was
appreciative but it wasn't like his
favorite thing that antique has ever
done no and when I popped it off you
were like oh my God you have a big thing
on your forehead and I was like I
figured I would I figured it would just
be there for like the next 10 minutes or
whatever
um no it's been three days I'm pretty
sure it's getting worse it's like purple
it's not getting worse it's getting
better
okay I just did order some Arnica Gel
that's what everyone told me it like
helps Bruce's heel um it's like what you
put on your face after Botox
and um it's pretty much been ruining my
life I went out Friday and Saturday
night and I had to cake on the most
makeup of all time I don't know how to
color correct I don't know what to do
with this thing I went to a dinner party
and got seated next to Martha Stewart
and I just know she was like in my
forehead the whole time I just feel like
if
it was which she wasn't and you're so
beautiful
noticed plus I saw the way you looked at
you really couldn't tell even with a
flash
um but she would have respected that it
was like an anti-related injury like
it's a funny story of course and Martha
is a grand like Martha knows the beauty
of you know being kind of like a a
second mother to a child yeah
so she and I had that in common which
was pretty cool like I got invited to
this dinner party
and I just took rsvp'd I didn't like
read the email or anything so I honestly
I got to stop doing that because I
didn't know like what I was walking into
I feel like I was like a little bit
underdressed
um and I go to my seat and I'm like
literally sitting next to Martha Stewart
and I was so excited and I really um I
did my best to like be cool and funny
and when she found out I was a comic she
was like I was asking her a million
questions like about Sports Illustrated
and she was so proud of Sports
Illustrated and I told her like what a
major moment it was for the culture and
how like we're so undeserving of
Martha's greatness you know and then we
were like chatting and I was asking her
a lot of questions about herself and
then she started to ask me and I was
like trying to be so funny and like
dazzling and I think I dazzled I think
she was like really I think she was into
me she kept like leaning to me and like
asking me questions about people around
us and I made her laugh a few times and
honestly once it made Martha laugh like
I knew I could go home if you could make
Martha laugh you can do anything
yeah because Martha's like very
very famous like it's actually crazy I
put I we posted I posted a photo of me
and Martha and I of course I was like
Martha do you like this photo do you
want me to face tune it and she was like
no I love it I'm like okay great I
didn't want to be disrespectful in any
way
um the amount of like that was probably
the most responses I've gotten to a
message like about posting ever with any
celebrity like Martha's
so famous it's kind of crazy no and it's
like she's famous for her taste taste
and her Acumen like it's a different
sort of
fame fame but it's also even like more
intimidating to sit next to her it's not
like she's like you know an amazing
actress and she's in these movies and
then that's separate from who she is
like she's famous for who she is in her
soul no but I would argue like depending
on how old you are like your connection
to Martha she's so multi-generationally
famous and like I'm sure different
people are obsessed with her for
different reasons I'm sure like a
younger crew is obsessed with like her
Snoop Dog thing but like an older woman
is more into like her pies you know yeah
it's she's so famous it was so crazy
she's so famous but I guess you're also
famous for your soul turdy so maybe you
guys have that for my soul yeah like for
who you are
I guess you know for like your your
person honestly I don't want to be
compared to Martha like are you trying
to destroy me like I'll become a monster
I don't know turdy Lou and Martha stew I
kinda
iconic do except like something probably
one of the worst things that could ever
happen to a human being happen to me at
this dinner party oh goodness oh do I
already know what it is yeah yeah yeah
okay I was like what else
so this dinner party was to honor this
like really major Egyptian archaeologist
he's like responsible for all of the
incredible discoveries in like the
pyramids the Sphinx he's so smart and
he's like this hilarious older gentleman
and Ben was talking to him his name is
Dr zahi hawas and he was just like he
made a little speech thanking everyone
for welcoming him to New York and he was
hysterical and Ben was talking to him
just he was asking questions about us
and Ben was like oh my wife does stand
up and he turns to me because he was
also sitting on the other side of me he
was like I love stand-up comedy and I
was like oh great me too he's like do
something I was like oh my God I will
die and everyone at the table was like
yeah do it do it so I was like okay I'll
do a little something for the table and
he's like no stand up because there were
four tables at this dinner party they're
like they're they start clinking their
glasses they're like do something for
everyone and I'm like oh my God oh my
God this is my worst nightmare
apparently but it's one of those
situations if I had said no like that's
such a losery thing to do Beyond that's
like when someone's like oh did you know
this person has an amazing voice and
then they won't sing for you like it's
[__] annoying yeah it's not the same
because like you can't just like do
comedy you know what I mean it's so
personal it's so personal but like I was
certainly like this man like is so the
mayor of New York came to the dinner
party like this man is so respect and he
wanted to hear me so I was like I have
to do it and I just you know what I was
actually really proud of myself I didn't
even I didn't I was like oh sure of
course like I didn't say no I stood up I
wasn't nervous I wanted to like feel
confident so I just felt confident I
just decided to be confident and I did
like a little bit from my um
from my special special which is coming
out soon and I haven't been on stage
since January so I was like kind of
rusty and I was just also just trying to
feel like the vibe of the crowd this was
like you know I'm intellectual
um sort of older crowd but they you know
they loved it Ben said I did a good job
I definitely wasn't like amazing I don't
think I was gonna you know get any
offers for you know private gigs but I
didn't embarrass myself and I did I
think I did good and I saw Dr zahi like
cackle at this one joke and that made me
feel so good I did like a few minutes I
really when it was over oh my God I I
was not okay like I was like I have to
leave yeah that's a lot but I'm proud of
you and that's really cool
no was really cool and I got to meet
Martha and hopefully Martha thought it
was funny so like I'm good yeah I'm sure
she did she's she's kind of like a comic
Queen
she is and I feel like she's so
unserious that's what's so surprising
about her like her whole vibe is like
Rich Coastal grandmother like expensive
weddings expensive homes at the beach
but like in her real life I feel like
she's like so low-key she was wearing
like sandals she was so chill yeah
very cool
yeah it was like a cool weekend and then
I got to hang out with Harry on Sunday
and he was biggest celeb biggest
archaeologist oh he's Excavating always
discovering new things constantly
digging dig
[Laughter]
and he was in if you were like are
around babies you know like they have
different moods and they're always that
cute and sweet but he was in like a
really special mood yesterday it was
actually as though he was delivered
Straight from Heaven like the way he
gave me so many kisses he was cackling
at antique joke
oh my God it was one of the more special
times of my life honestly it was better
than Martha no offense Martha I Love You
Queen oh that's so beautiful yeah you
got him at um at the right time at his
finest yeah it was amazing you know it
was a really nice weekend got to see my
turdy Lou and
catch up
can we give like a bed rest update to
everyone like how are you feeling how
are you doing what's going on yeah I'm
feeling
um as good as possible you know just
trying to
stay busy as you know and
just but I I weirdly I'm really busy
like I'm not bored I feel like at the
end of my pregnancy with Harry I was
also weirdly like just in bed all the
time because I wasn't leaving the house
um and I don't feel like that where I'm
just like stir crazy well because you're
also like a full-time mother there's so
much from the bed right from the bed
like we're still podcasting like I still
have other work to do and so like the
day kind of like my day still has like
structure and routines that I'm just
like kind of doing everything from the
bed but no I feel good just you know um
for everyone who like knows the whole
story of the cervix like I'm just trying
to
keep it tight keep it closed you're
really pregnant like you have you
honestly like have like a round belly
yeah it's mad big and like all the you
know pregnancy like all your organs are
like compressed and so I'm just like
short of breath and oh no it's like it's
just a lot but it's all good
okay thank God fabulous we love the bed
I was having this conversation at dinner
with Taylor strecker because she um
her and Taylor are like always asking
about you making sure you're good and
she was like is Jackie Like Loving
better ass like hating bad rest cause
like for me you know bedrat sounds like
heaven I'm like no same but Jackie has
like a one-year-old like it's not the
same like it's actually torture yeah
it's not the same it's actually torture
and it's like I'm in New York and
there's so many things that like I wish
I could be doing here but I guess like
if I wouldn't be in New York if not for
like the circumstances so it's like
right fruitless to just be like I wish
we could be doing this and that but
there's like you know there's a couple
things it's like it would be so nice to
just be able to go and do right what I
can't do even like going to the studio
is like a treat yeah and I'm here and I
can't do it but it is what it is no and
Harry's loving life in New York yeah he
is he loves the adventure he's booked
and busy every day I can't even get time
with him on the calendar yeah you got to
get on his schedule
his schedules are kind of crazy
it's kind of crazy yeah it's kind of
crazy because he wakes up at six so like
you know and then it's like you spend
before you even wake up no and it's like
I wake up in podcast and then by the
time I'm done podcasting how are you
ready for a snap yep
so it's like I can't really like
logically see him on the weekdays before
two o'clock yeah because like have lunch
you guys don't sink really before one
it's true it sucks
and something that I've just been kind
of waiting to say
um since uh a few minutes ago is that
what I noticed yeah is that underneath
your sweatshirt today it seems as though
you're wearing spooky scary skeleton
pajamas a new addition yeah okay I put
these on intentionally to podcast with
you from home I wanted to give you like
a little bit of a spook but then right
before we started I got freezing so I
put a sweatshirt on on top so I know you
can't see I'm wearing yeah you can't get
by me I'm wearing matching pants and top
of my new spooky scary skeleton pajamas
for those who know who've been following
for a while the pajamas I wore pretty
much every day for the last five years
have disintegrated and I did toss them
people were really mad they're like how
could you not keep them like take them
to the tailor okay I'm like okay we need
to know this you don't know the sweeper
I think you don't know this either
that's true not only do I sweep like I
my house like if there's clutter it's
gone in a second I don't have anything I
don't need in this house but also like
we're headed for a recession like I'm
not about to you know spend a hundred
dollars repairing a pair of pajamas from
Target okay like we have to logic has
entered the room yeah and she's the
sweeper that was like when we were
talking about sandwiches people were
giving us recommendations they're like
turdy you have to try like cheese mayo
lettuce and tomato I'm like have you met
turkey are you new here they said Mayo
Mayo can you imagine somebody telling me
that
they said well it's nice to have new
toasters you know so I'm not gonna knock
it I'm not gonna knock it I'm so
thankful it's a sign of new life it's a
sign of new life if you guys don't know
that turdy would never touch mail with a
10-foot pole
um yet her husband is made of mayo yeah
then well you know what the toast we
should do a patreon kind of like those
games they play on watch Robin's live
wood turdy eat it and you just like
rattle off things and I probably
wouldn't eat most of them so the answer
is no yeah it would just be like kind of
a boring episode like no no no no no
yeah but there's some weird things that
you eat like too true cottage cheese
yeah I guess that's the only one
no I also weirdly eat do you like the
filter fish
Jackie
bffr
be [__] for real yeah but sometimes
you'll put aside your
your distaste for things like when it
comes to your culture
varnishka Kasha varnishkas like you
would never catch me eating lentils but
Kasha varnishka the traditional Eastern
European dish love right so that's why I
feel like a filter fish isn't that crazy
no it is
of all like the Jewish foods that's
probably the craziest one and Claudia
there's like crazy like intestines like
oh yeah like creploch yeah
but I still I stand by that gefilte is
like still one of the crazier ones okay
you just gotta get a little horseradish
on it so absolutely not that's so never
gonna happen
so good
um look I guess I guess right we could
Dive In
I guess
if we must
yeah yeah they're yeah there's some
things that we need to discuss
that need 30 minutes take
I guess I just like would so much prefer
to keep talking about ourselves I know I
can't believe but live I can't believe
how like the Fast Five is really in its
flop era no it is Jack and I were having
this conversation before we recorded
because she spent 40 minutes looking for
stories and when it shouldn't be that
hard
um and the Fast Five is definitely in
its flop era but I don't feel like it
has anything to do with us it is the
summer everything no matter you know
what industry you work in I guess unless
you work in like pools but the the
summer is slow for everyone and
everything celebrities yeah celebrities
are like sunblock you know or if you
live in like a summer Beach Town yeah
like if you're like in Montauk or
something like cousins but like besides
that do you like my reference to the
kids cousins I did besides that like
it's notoriously slow for a lot of
Industries pop culture being one of them
celebrities are in Greece in the south
of France they're not making news like
they're taking the summer off so I don't
feel bad that the Fast Five it's in its
flop era honestly yeah no and it's like
just like anything else you know it
comes in waves and things go up and down
like it's not
has nothing to do with a premise or
anything it's just
it's crazy but maybe that's just because
we're like also we in our personal
banter
are in our what's the opposite of flop
era
um
I don't know wait that's like a really
good question like peeking
yeah I guess
you know I guess because oh my God I did
something so crazy the other day and I
watched a little bit of an episode of
the toast from April 2018 the first
month of the toast which is like how I
know you think
it would be horrible and like that I
would that it's self-harm to do such a
thing
yeah but honestly it was really cute and
God no Jackie my mole I was so ugly that
was before my chin surgery before my
mole removal okay fine but you but you
sat on your other side so like we didn't
see your mom okay okay obviously like it
wasn't perfect and I'm so glad we got
rid of YouTube live because we were
always just looking at our phones
reading the comments like yeah yeah like
waiting for people to respond so lame
but one it was really cute and two we
literally got into the Fast Five after
one minute of speaking no I mean I'm
looking at my my computer right now it's
been 30 minutes I know but I was like
shocked I was like girls what's going on
in your lives why are we getting into
the stories maybe we had nothing going
on honestly I that was kind of you know
a dark time for us a quiet time for us
it was quiet on all fronts social
personal business yeah maybe that's what
it was but honestly I was mostly
surprised with how little I cringed
considering like oh that's a good thing
that I that is in the rear view is
cringe-worthy to me yes but I actually
that feels familiar I feel like when
I've seen like old clips like we're so
funny yeah we're just like cute and
we're having fun and we're young and
taking a chance you know trying
something new putting ourselves out
there starting our own business like
it's sweet when we started the toast we
truly were the definition of two people
with nothing to lose like we had nothing
like literally we didn't have a brand
deal like we were so we were like
Renegade The Outlaws radioactive like we
had nothing to lose and honestly there's
truly nothing funnier than somebody with
nothing to lose yeah but I feel like as
much as yeah we had nothing to lose to
we were we were willing to you know put
it all out there and we weren't like
embarrassed or anything but I also feel
like we were we were really scared
you know I would know by the way we were
like Renegade be just like being crazy
no we we so desperately wanted and
needed this show to be good like we
needed it to work we had had a
successful show and we were like we are
not going down like this yeah and we
just like wanted people to like us like
we were just like
no I felt like my name had been like
besmirched if that's the correct word
and I felt so strongly that people were
wrong about us like they you know ever
we got canceled everybody hated us and
they were wrong about us because like we
are funny we are amazing we are such we
I know we are like I know who we are we
are an amazing group of people and I was
I was
motivated to make people see that
because I felt like they're wrong they
are wrong about us and they were yeah
it's true and they were look at us now
oh baby look at us now look at us now 32
minutes of pretty fast five look at us
now podcasting from home in spooky scary
skeleton Pajamas not much has changed
spooky scary Yeah the more things change
the more they stay the same spooky scary
skeletons and shivers down your spine
gorgeous okay now we all right I guess
now I guess yeah go without further Ado
here you go here are the fast five
stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by skims all
right you guys undies bras Jax and I
have been through them all but the fits
everybody collection from skims is the
best we are no longer keeping the secret
to ourselves the underwear feels like
nothing we've ever worn before it is so
stretchy and soft it melts into your
body and you forget you're even wearing
it when it comes to bras and undies Jax
and I are two girls with needs we are
two very particular girls and I'm not
gonna lie when I heard about the skims
fits everybody collection I was like
okay yeah I'm sure it fits everybody but
not me but not me like I have so many
different issues I have like rolls and
pouches like it's just not it's not for
everyone but skims is the solution
oriented brand creating the next
generation of underwear loungewear and
shapewear for everybody
so Jackie and I are two busty girls
Jackie obviously has been through
breastfeeding I just have the biggest
hits of all time like we have different
needs and our favorite favorite bras we
like to call them are relaxation bras
are from skims so I found out about
these ones on Tick Tock and they are
everything so the racerback bralette is
the one I wear like around the house
because I can't I'm not one of those
girls who can just walk around without
wearing a bra
um it's fabulous and by the way Jackie
was the one who said to me when I was
having crazy back problems she's like
you need a new bra you need a new bra
and I now every single day wear the
T-shirt bra
from skims and I have to tell you my
back problems are nearly non-existent I
and I'm being dead serious that fits
everybody collection of underwear are
lightweight form-fitting and essential
The Buttery soft fabric molds to your
body and stretches to twice its size
believe the hype this collection has
over 90 000 5 Star reviews for a reason
skims fits everybody collection and more
best-selling Essentials are available
now at skims.com plus get free shipping
on orders of over 75 dollars all at
skims.com today's episode is also
brought to you by a life-saving product
that I heavily relied on this weekend
liquid IV proper functional hydration is
essential and liquid ID is a number one
powered hydration brand in America their
hydration brand multiplier is the one
product you're missing in your daily
routine use it first thing in the
morning before a workout when you feel a
little run down in the afternoon after a
night out with friends or on Long
flights I always have one in my travel
bag and I cannot tell you how many times
it has saved my life on a trip whether
I'm dehydrated from drinking or just so
much travel and like forgetting to drink
water
with just one stick you can hydrate
two times faster than water alone and
you're gonna get a ton of essential
vitamins liquid IV comes in 12 delicious
refreshing flavors to keep your
hydration routine exciting the flavors
are really good the vitamins that they
have are B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C and
it's just so easy to down it you're
getting hydrated you're getting a boost
of vitamins it's made with quality
ingredients it's non-GMO and it's free
from gluten dairy and soy they partner
with leading organizations to fund and
Foster innovative solutions that help
communities protect both their water and
their Futures so to date liquid IV has
donated over 39 million servings in over
50 countries around the world so you can
feel good about what you're purchasing
knowing you're making a difference real
people real flavor real hydrating grab
your liquid IV in bulk nationwide at
Costco or you can get 20 off when you go
to liquid iv.com and use code toast at
checkout this is just something you want
to have in your house all the time you
never know when you're going to need it
and you don't want to like need it and
not have it that's 20 off anything when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code toast at liquid iv.com
thank you Claudia
you're welcome
our first story some new couple news
milkshake singer Kelis is reportedly
dating actor Bill Murray
I'm having a stroke shook confused I'm
feeling scared like I have quite
literally no idea what's going on right
okay so the U.S Sun reported that Kelis
who's 43 is reportedly dating the
Ghostbusters actor who is 72 per the
outlet the two sparked romance rumors
after Bill Murray watched the bossy
singer perform at a recent show at the
mighty hoopla Festival in South London
last weekend he was also spotted
supporting her at some of her other
performances sources close to the pair
told the Sun that they were also seen
together at the same hotel and have been
getting close for a while after first
meeting in the U.S
also she posted
um some bikini pics from Greece this
weekend and seemed to respond to the
rumors because someone commented ma'am
would you care to address these Bill
Murray allegations because damn what's
he doing with all that and she said LOL
no babe I wouldn't bother at all so I
feel like she's saying I wouldn't bother
to comment on these rumors yeah right
right not that she wouldn't bother with
Bill Murray right but who who knows I
mean but I'm choosing to believe this
couple and I ship I really do okay
here's what's so funny because when you
were like saying their age difference I
was like oh that's like really not so
bad like she's 42.
um but like if he was 40 and she was 10
like like the 30. you know what I mean
like the 30 years like it's actually a
lot for sure 30 years is a lot but you
cannot compare the 30 years between 10
and 40 to the 30 years between 40 and
70. of course by the way my math was
wrong I'm sorry I didn't I didn't mean
to make a joke out of that four not 40
and 10 like 20 and 50. we would be like
ew but that's because like a 20 year old
brain like isn't fully developed and
they're not like mature enough even
still like the older you get like those
big age gaps aren't as big of a deal
because like you are who you are at that
point like and there's not that much the
rapid development that happens when
you're younger like really slows down
once you get older so yes I think we're
gonna say 42 year old man and 72 year
old woman if we would be saying the same
thing it would depend on the couple
honestly I think I would I think I'd be
saying the same thing on yeah I ship too
to be honest I wasn't entirely familiar
with
um
her like I obviously no milkshake but I
don't like know her as a person or like
an artist so if anything like Bill
Murray kind of making her a star is is
everything yeah I'm totally here for it
I feel like people are really surprised
but but are here for it still positive
yes I agree and I can't I don't keep up
with Bill Murray either so I don't
really know like what the what the read
is on him like there's some bad stuff
like is he not like beloved he was
beloved and then like very recently I
think he was like fired from a movie or
there was like I'm not entirely sure but
like there were some weird things he was
being accused of like you know not being
like the most appropriate got it so
that's starting to ring familiar I feel
like we had a story on it yes right but
like for so long he was like and I think
he still is like considered one of the
greatest comedy actors
um and very well respected but I do
think he's had like you know uh uh
changing likability over the last few
years yeah just like his shtick hasn't
aged well right right and you know what
you can't be doing comedy for that long
without you know without the
consequences
yeah so I mean to me this is like an
age-appropriate relationship weirdly
yeah and so uh I should it's cute yeah I
have them quite literally no problem
with this yeah wishing them wishing them
the best honestly wishing them the best
our next story some other not new couple
news but just two people in the same
room and I want to take your temperature
okay
a source says that Irena Shake threw
herself at Tom Brady at an A-list
wedding this weekend and you would do it
too
[Laughter]
spies told page six at Fame model arena
shake made a b line for newly single Tom
Brady
um at the much talked about wedding of
Joe Namath and Madison Hedrick last week
and scarcely let him out of her sight
throughout the weekend long festivities
but Shake's manager strenuously denied
that account telling page six it's
totally fictional but they were both
guests at the billionaire art heirs
wedding in Sardinia last week
okay well let's just like talk about
this as if it's true because let me just
say how I can see this being true
because um Irina Shake is a a woman you
know she's a human being and even though
she's perfect and is dated you know the
finest men that this country has to
offer
she's still human and Tom Brady is the
most eligible bachelor right now and
like she like her taste is the finest
men that this country has to offer Tom
Brady is that note and Tom Brady's taste
is the finest woman model honestly Irina
shake and Giselle are so similar looking
and they have like really similar Vibes
um I could see her thinking oh he would
be into me he was into Giselle yeah Noah
like this is such a duh I can't believe
we didn't think of it sooner yeah right
I do hope that they conversed this
weekend I feel like all they would need
to do is have a conversation to realize
like oh we should date even if it even
if we don't work out like you're my type
I'm your type we're both single duh no
Juggy like Irina Shake is copy and paste
Giselle Tom Brady is copy and paste
Bradley Cooper like this is literally
the same couple but just like a little
different yeah
yeah it makes it makes a lot of sense I
mean I found my arena shake and people
are saying this about me I'm mortified
no whether it was true or not like the
most desperate things about Irina shake
like that about how she's so desperate
like how she's so desperate to have
Bradley back like that she just Moves In
A desperate way and I don't know if
that's just who she is or like someone's
out to get her but no by the way it's
not nice
somebody's totally out together because
like the last couple of things we've
like spoken about her it's like she's
not like coming off looking amazing and
she's constantly coming off like she's
conning Bradley Cooper into getting back
together with her yes she's like staging
photos to make it look like they're
together when they're not and I don't
know who's doing this to her but she has
enemies
yeah either she has enemies or she's a
desperate person and honestly if she's a
desperate person like I've truly like I
never thought I would have anything in
common with Irina shaken like it really
makes me relate to her like even the
most beautiful women in the world are
like desperate for attention and love
and you know what
that's the great equalizer desperation
yeah but I guess like when your type is
the greatest men that this country has
to offer like
you got to be desperate yeah you it's a
hard place to be like me if she could
like lower her
bar a little bit like there would be
more men like more a bigger pool and she
wouldn't have to act so desperately
I just want to say like obviously I'm a
married woman and I'm not you know like
a great Beauty I'm not like one of the
most beautiful women I'm not like one of
the most beautiful women in the country
but like if I was can I tell you and I
really feel like this be true like I
feel like I would not be going after the
Tom Brady's and the Bradley Coopers like
it's too much pressure I feel like
they're so much better in like idea than
they are in actuality I feel like you
know they're not gonna have like the
best personalities and then it's like I
have to be perfect my whole life because
like men age so well like I would
honestly like no and I feel like I say
this all the time like nobody has has
designed a life better for themselves
than Miranda Kerr
so what would you go for
I would go for like the tech billionaire
nerd who's like still cute and handsome
but he's not like the greatest hottest
like Evan Spiegel is very handsome he's
like a cute Jewish nerd he will age
normally like he's not Bradley Cooper
He's not Tom Brady like he's very normal
and Miranda Kerr is still at the top of
her game but like maybe the time will
come where she doesn't want to be so
beautiful anymore like she could just
relax you know yeah I do still think
like he is a choice that's still at that
like
level of no he's not at the same level
as Tom Brady no no just because like Tom
Bradley and Bradley Cooper like yeah
they're like not real
right but still like with Evan Spiegel
you gotta behave still 30. of course of
course of course but like I feel like
the pressure with an Evan Spiegel is so
much better than the pressure with like
a Bradley Cooper
yeah yeah I agree
like I just I look at her I've recently
started following Miranda Kerr on like
every social media platform
um and she's she's killing it like like
but also he is like the most handsome
Tech Mogul so like she went for the
handsome one okay there's not like so
much competition with like handsome Tech
Moguls they're not like a lot of
handsome ones
so yes I agree with that but it's a
different pool than like the upper
echelona plus you know who's another
person who did it right
Jasmine tooks who's she with okay so her
husband I just I want to get this right
honestly low-key all a lot of those
model girls
having really nice marriages
okay he is a businessman and media
personality who also works at Snapchat
that's why I had an association he's the
director of international markets but
they had this like insane wedding
um
I believe he's like very high up in
government or like he has like
something oh sorry yes he's the son of
Ecuadorian vice president so when they
got married I think they got married
somewhere and it was like fancy and like
they were like diplomats and stuff like
she runs in a fabulous circle of people
okay let me ask you about another one
sure Rosie Huntington Whiteley and Jason
Statham
okay very interesting as well because
he's like technically like a good
looking actor but he's he's a real
person I feel
like yeah okay so he's a good looking
actor but like when you see these two
people together like she's infinitely
better looking than him like if he was a
regular dude like sorry nobody would
think he was handsome he's just handsome
because he's like an actor and he's cute
he's not like no he's handsome he's
really handsome and he's like he has
something very like he's always playing
like a a handsome Jason he's Jason
Bourne that's what it is so he's like
you know a daredevil like Tom like a
bond type yeah yeah that's handsome
yeah I mean but she's much taller than
him like I think they're evenly matched
and I think they're like a real love
match I think they've been in love for
like a really long time and I I ship and
I love I think she also did very well
yeah
it's so interesting like you really you
obviously have a lot of options when
you're a part of like the most beautiful
women in the world but you want to make
like a lasting marriage and I think
these three women did an amazing job and
you got to get creative a little bit
like you don't go for the office Choice
that's what I'm saying you don't go
forth and I wouldn't either no but Irina
Shake keeps going for the obvious yeah
memories with Kanye like it's just so
obvious like come on girl like you need
to punch down just a little bit I think
if you really want to make it work yeah
hopefully she'll hear this
hopefully she'll hear this but I hope
she got a date with Tom Brady
win a date with Tom Brady
are you ready for our next story yeah
Shawn Mendes is causing a little
controversy with his new single and you
know what album art and you know what
like I'm about to become like a Karen
because I'm with the people giving back
lash which I never am but it's a
question mark yeah no Shawn Mendes was
slammed for using a photo of New York
City engulfed in Wildfire smoke to
promote his new single so he came out
with a song on Friday and it's called
what the hell are we all done what the
hell are we dying for and the artwork
for the single is the pictures of New
York like the one of the pictures of New
York Orange from last week right and the
you know New York was orange because
like people's homes are burning down
like it's not
cool to use that as wildfires yes oh and
let's keep in mind uh Sean is a Canadian
King like this felt very bizarre and
like this is just one of those
situations where it's like you know many
people had to approve this or like you
know make the artwork and not one of
them was like is this a bad idea yeah
that is weird
it's just weird and I feel like he was
intentionally provocative but it's like
not doing what he thinks it's doing yeah
no and it's like I'm all actually about
being intentionally provocative
but I don't see what like the good side
of this provocation is like I only see
this like feeling icky and weird and
what was the artwork gonna be before
um before last year right right because
he like posted this on like Friday and
literally the Wildfire like smoke ended
in New York on Friday yeah and it was
like I'm sure he recorded the song the
week before like what was the plan
before that right like that picture he
used was taken Thursday yeah was that
Thursday that was like the worst day
really no Wednesday and no it was both
actually they were both Wednesday and
Thursday were both terrible
okay
but this is you know I hate to jump on a
band when I get a backlash because most
of the time backlash is moronic and like
okay we shouldn't kill Sean Mendes but
like no this was definitely a bad choice
like I'm I'm just not I actually don't
think there's that much backlash like
considering how [__] weird it is
maybe just because like Shawn Mendes is
like not on everyone's radar uh it's not
like it's like taking over headline news
yes like Shawn Mendes canceled it's just
like oh that's [__] weird
yeah I feel like this is just one of
those situations where a celebrity is
they really like don't live in the real
world and every now and then we get a
glimpse of like how out of touch they
are and this is just one of those things
it was giving it's giving like imagine
video yeah and I also could see it like
people on his team being like I don't
know Sean I don't know if that's your
best idea and him being like no this is
it this is important like this is the
message this is the moment totally like
kind of like what are we doing if we're
not doing this and like pushing it down
the field and making it happen because I
I could I think a lot of people would
see this and be like I don't know Sean
this feels off yeah by the way him and
Camilla broken
why
I don't know I guess they like tried to
give it another chance you know maybe
they broke up and sometimes you just
need closure
but they broke up
understand why they clearly love each
other so much do you think they bring up
over this picture no they broke up
before they broke up before maybe she
knew maybe she was the one trying to
tell him yeah
yeah I could see that yeah because I
feel like Camilla's like definitely
really connected to like her fans in the
real world and like maybe Shawn's just
like a little too because Sean's much
more famous and maybe that's like the
underlying issue in their relationship
all the time it's like he's he lives in
a fantasy world yeah and then this was
like the straw that broke the camel's
back it's like if you think that that's
good PR normal we clearly have less in
common than I thought
yeah maybe this was a straw that broke
the camel's back even though that's
probably not at all what happened it's
the narrative I choose to believe
I'm with you girl especially when they
don't give us anything like so I'll make
something up so I'll make it up
literally and then the one thing they do
give us is the picture of the Canada
Wildfire right this is all I have from
this week and I know that they broke up
I'm gonna say the two are related the
two are inextricably linked
well wishing them the best I didn't hear
Sean's new song not that I like really
would listen to like a new Sean Mendes
song like the second it comes out but I
definitely was like oh Shawn Mendes is
like in like a weird space right now
because he just put out this weird thing
he is in a weird space and no he is not
dating Sabrina
no he's not and maybe that's what's
wrong
Maybe
I don't know Shaman just has good songs
though like when I do listen to them
in my blood like that's a [__] popping
song do you got plans tonight
I'm a couple hundred miles from Japan
and I that's a good song yeah and the
other one Blended or something
also to see the song called Wonder yeah
I wonder what it's like to be loved by
you
by Blended for me
what maybe you're just like always
thinking about that Drew Barrymore movie
Blended maybe but you know what I'm
going through my Shawn Mendes
um does he have a song called Blended no
I think it was Wonder I think it was
Wonder but it's just like one word song
you know yeah sure
um also I think one of Shawn Mendes's
better songs is the first song he ever
released after Vine it's like giving
very much like soundtrack to a Disney
Channel movie it's called something big
something big I feel it happening Adam
my control so good oh he's also on The
Descendants soundtrack
a Disney thing with a song called
believe that's in my saved songs must be
good must be good
well I just hope you know Sean Mendes
can learn and grow from this and do
better
I hope so too
the thing is I don't think that he's
going to like I don't think he's
apologized or anything like he's taking
a stand
yeah no he's like hey this is what I was
haters be damned like this is what I
want to say this is the moment
that's what he's saying so I don't think
there'll be any doing better from him
damn that's so Sean
oh Sean
okay let's get into our next story is it
the next story that's brought to you by
Squarespace per chance
yes it is
Squarespace is everything to sell
anything Squarespace has the tools you
need to get your business off the ground
including e-commerce templates Inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
Squarespace has merchandising features
to make your products look their best
online so head to squarespace.com toast
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code toast to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain whatever you want to
create a website for whether you want to
get into blogging e-commerce whatever it
is show off your stunning portfolio of
Photography videography Squarespace is
the perfect place to start I feel like
creating websites should not be that
hard like you don't need a computer
science degree to use Squarespace and
you will your result will look like a
website that was made by like a fancy
company so whenever whether you're using
it for e-commerce social media
Squarespace has the best tools like they
have traffic overview so you can see how
your visits unique visitors page views
are trending over time you can gain
insight into the top traffic sources
products device types browsers and
operating systems they also offer
content ownership so you own all the
content you put on Squarespace platform
they offer a one-click data portability
they can help you with email campaigns
if you want to grow and engage your
audience with the Squarespace email
campaigns you can create powerful email
content that matches your website with
your existing products blog posts and
Logo you can also share on social the
Squarespace blogging platform supports a
configurable share button letting your
visitor share content on the Facebook
Twitter Google Plus LinkedIn StumbleUpon
Reddit Pinterest and Tumblr pages
so again if you want to take control go
to squarespace.com toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
today's episode is also brought to you
by our friends at the perfect bar the
original refrigerated protein bar that
you know and love if you haven't heard
perfect bar just launched a new line of
protein bars called perfect bar layers
so the layers are a new line of crispy
protein bars stacked with three
delicious layers and packed with whole
food nutrition they're made with a
crispy base of peanut butter and cashew
butter and they're layered with dark
chocolate or 100 real fruit and then
they're sprinkled with toasted
gluten-free oats they're packed with up
to 11 grams of proteins they come in two
delicious flavors crispy peanut butter
and chocolate and the crispy peanut
butter and Berry which is basically like
a healthy peanut butter and jelly
because they're made with only whole
food ingredients their classic blend of
20 organic superfoods and they contain
no artificial preservatives perfect bar
layers are stored in the fridge so you
could say that these bars are stacked
and packed and honestly the fact that
they're kept in the fridge brings me so
much peace of mind and makes me question
every other bar that's not like how
gross is that if you aren't already
convinced they're also non-GMO project
verified gluten-free soy free kosher and
low GI the best part is that you can now
find them in the refrigerated section at
Targets Nationwide perfect bar knows
that it'll be Love At First Bite so
they're offering you a chance to try
their new refrigerated protein bars for
free here's how it works sign up for
email or text and upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they'll reimburse you for the
cost of one bar it'll go directly into
your venmoa or PayPal account all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast to get that free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking
thank you Claudia you're welcome Jackie
you actually just made me really want a
perfect bar but I'll wait
yeah because you eat on this podcast and
you get killed it's so true
is this the fifth Story it's the fourth
oh I'm just thinking of ways that you
could eat on a podcast and get away with
it
maybe you guys could figure that out one
day maybe I could figure that out one
day until then I'll starve
next so Chloe and Tristan's son Tatum
had uh the last name Kardashian at Birth
and later changed it to Thompson TMZ
reports so Chloe wasn't messing around
when her son was born giving him the
last name Kardashian instead of
Tristan's last name but later had a
change of heart sources with direct
knowledge tell us Tatum Thompson as he's
now known was initially legally a
Kardashian the sources say Tatum also
wasn't his first name though we're not
sure what first name Chloe originally
chose for the kiddo eventually Chloe
decided to drop the Kardashian name and
now to hate him's legal name is Tatum
Thompson moving forward I think at first
he was baby because she couldn't decide
on a name and that's also something that
we've seen in um this season so far is
like her being not unsure of his name
but like they are calling him Robert I
think for a while like maybe his name
was going to be Robert or maybe like
Chris really wanted it to be Robert and
she decided on Tatum Robert so another
one who's having a journey with her
child's name
yeah and also I think people are looking
into this is like you know Chloe and
Tristan's relationship but
I'm sure she wants Tatum to have the
same last name is true I think Chloe
went with the T names because Thompson
like Khloe Kardashian true Thompson it's
like an alliteration thing so I don't
think there's like this means anything
yeah
well no I mean the only thing that means
to me is like when she initially
like that yeah I guess she must have
maybe she was just mad at him maybe but
I think or she knew that um the name was
gonna change because if it was like baby
Kardashian when at first until she came
up with Tatum like if she knew it was
gonna change eventually then she could
add the Thompson
yeah yeah I'm just choosing like not to
look into this too much you know no but
it's just interesting and again to me
I'm like now so interested in one like
celebrity baby names to like the baby
naming experience in general and three
like baby name trepidation and regret
okay let me ask you a question at this
point in your first pregnancy did you
know that you were gonna go with Harry
yes like Harry's always been like a boy
name that I loved and that our family
has loved and now for little baby Larry
you have nothing no no I have I have
choices which is actually more than I
had for Harry like I didn't really have
um a second choice for Harry and except
for Wolf
um and that was only the week before
when Kylie named her baby wolf
somebody needs to use that name like
it's so cool it's such a cute name but
it's just like
it was like Kylie said like he's not a
wolf so if you don't have a world and
there's no way to know when they're born
whether or not they will be a wolf
well we know now like Harry was a wolf
and you think his name should be wolf no
no but he could have been wolf yeah like
he would have carried the name with
pride yeah so now I feel like more like
how most people feel which is just like
we have a bunch of choices and I'm just
waiting to see each day I feel like more
akin to a different choice
and I also will wait
like I'm not making any decisions yet
but it's just so hard I know
it's so hard it is so hard and you could
see Chloe struggling with it in this
episode and she said they're not allowed
to call him Tate I think Tate is such a
cute name I think it's the cutest thing
ever like tater tot like Tate's cookies
my favorite
he I actually love the name Tate love
and Tatum but Chris tried to call him
team she said no
that was also like just an interesting
scene in that um most recent episode I
just felt like Chloe was like just she's
struggling through it yeah she was just
struggling and she wasn't her normal
bubbly welcoming effervescent self like
she's like having like a tough time with
this baby and I think like in a few
months like maybe she'll come around to
Tate I just think she was like in a bad
mood and she was just like she was just
saying no to life yeah no she's going
through like a hard period in life in
general like she had the cancerous
um
sell on her face and she has like this
drama with Tristan she's like very
anxious in general and just like having
a hard time in the public eye and she's
like struggling with having a new baby
that she didn't give birth to and like
struggling to bond with the baby and and
didn't anticipate that whatsoever I have
to say Chloe has shared a lot on the
show
um but I thought her you know being
honest about how surrogacy was like not
what she thought it was going to be was
so probably one of the most honest
things I've heard anyone say I'm sure at
some point she felt like shame
associated with that and like didn't
want to share it but the fact that she
did is like so like Chloe is constantly
out here like laying it all out for this
show and she's really like the unsung
hero of the show no it's true and like
maybe people even like if you watch the
episode Chloe's like not giving what she
usually gives but I actually think she's
giving more of course because she's
really going through it being and like
saying things that not many people have
said or would say yeah and like I'm sure
she was feeling like people would judge
her for it but like honestly I feel like
it's the most
Brave honest thing anybody's ever said
on reality TV I I like I I was shocked
when I heard it yeah yeah I love Chloe
like she's really
Far and Away the best character on the
show close second to Chris
oh for me right now it's Chloe and Kyla
yeah but Kylie's just not on it a lot
like but she just couldn't do no wrong
by me right now no and she's just so
fabulous and I feel like she's made it a
point for like a really long time to not
let people like know who she really is
like I think the only the people around
her know I think she's like kind of
quirky and weird we don't know that like
she shows us what she wants to show us
she had that privilege because she was
the youngest and by the time it was her
time to shine the show was successful
they didn't need her to like bleed out
and
every time we get like a little glimpse
into her actual personality it's so
interesting but we don't get a lot no we
don't
but she's like kind of crazy but maybe
that's how she maintains like a pretty
good head on her shoulders because yes
like
I feel like Kendall struggles with that
I feel like everything Kendall like
wants to put herself out there like
she's brutally rebuffed by the fans and
like everything she's like roasted picks
apart everything that she does and she
already like has anxiety struggles and I
feel like Kylie actually has a pretty
sound mental health probably because she
delineates really well like what she'll
share of herself agreed I agree and she
like became a mom so young so she like
took time off especially when things
were like at the height of like her Fame
in particular like she went M.I.A like
she was
pregnant and then like not sharing she
really I feel like of all them
has like the healthiest balance and
that's like a privilege because she was
the youngest and like so much was done
for her yes
I wonder if any of the girls like
rosenter for that
oh I'm sure there that they probably
more so resent her for like not filming
and not opening up and sharing
right but then like becoming a
billionaire first for like all the work
that kind of you know the OG girlies did
yeah
I'm sure there's some of that but not
enough because she keeps doing what
she's doing like they don't get her into
like joining the show in a real way
right and it just I think it's
interesting how there's uh obviously
like a conversation and we're still
having it we had it on the old show and
we're having it now about Courtney's
commitment to filming when Kylie like
does less
yeah but I think it's like when the
family sits down and they like talk
about do we want to do another season I
think Kylie probably votes no like yeah
and
it's just I don't know no it's
interesting it is interesting because I
actually think like however they split
up their money from Hulu I don't know
how it how it's done Kylie does not need
that to live but I actually believe
Courtney probably does yeah maybe maybe
not that she's like in a marriage with
someone who's like equally as successful
as her
um and if they share finances like I'm
sure that's great but like between Lemmy
push like she needs the show yeah no and
also when she was doing the Today Show
on last week's episode and she said how
like for all those years like everyone
was like what's your brand what's your
brand and she's like I'm doing the show
this is my full-time job so that's her
job yeah right right because I just
don't think she has enough wealth to
like not continue to work forever yeah
agreed which yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I Jen
yeah I am you are okay because it's an
interesting conversation that's
happening the types are kind of turning
a little bit in the world of scandaval
very slowly but
um there's been a shift so first Lala
Kemp was captured uh talking to
Paparazzi uh TMZ caught her at the
airport and she's kind of giving more of
a changing tune on Raquel so yeah Lala
changed her attitude toward Raquel after
watching her Scandal scarred co-star cry
and tell the truth about her affair with
Tom on Vanderpump Rules Lala said when
she finally had the breakdown just as a
human for me it's like it's a reality TV
show when I watched that I was like oh
we may be dealing with someone who maybe
shouldn't be on this type of platform
when asked whether she had become more
empathetic and less angry at Raquel she
sarcastically replied and my empathetic
shocker I don't know how other people
feel about the last five minutes but I
did sit there and go she needs some real
help and I pray that she got it
yeah they're definitely and that's what
we had said right when we recapped
Vanderpump Rules third reunion is like
it felt like not that she was doing it
intentionally but I wouldn't be
surprised if there was like a wave of of
sympathy for Raquel because when you
can't watch that and think that that
person is like is okay
she was not in any way okay and
I think now in hindsight like everybody
now it's done and we're all just like
looking at the situation like at a
glance kind of like the chapter is
closed and in no way has Tom Sandoval
had any redeeming moments I still think
he's very much the villain of this whole
story and like he's actually a bad
person not a person who made a mistake I
think Raquel is a person who made a
mistake because she's so vulnerable and
easily manipulated and clearly has
mental health issues like she
it kind of seemed like during you know
the Fallout she was very much
disassociating like which I think is a
natural
reaction to like protect yourself and
people were like that gave people even
more fuel like she's not remorseful and
then we saw the moment where like all of
the consequences of her actions finally
hit her and I think I think it it
probably
um like destroyed her
and that's what we saw
I feel like people are definitely
even one degree more sympathetic towards
Raquel after one she came clean I feel
like it's even you know in like a a
police case it's like the person who
tells the truth that gets a less harsh
sentence yeah and I feel like that's how
it is right now like we just appreciate
that she's being honest and she's
exposing Tom Sandoval like even further
um but there's also this small
conversation that I'm starting to see
people saying of the way that Raquel was
treated at the reunion was not something
that was acceptable and even though
everyone is hurt and everyone has their
feelings like the way she was spoken to
the things that were said to her are not
how you treat fellow human beings yes
and you know what I I don't fully
disagree with that I think it's also
just that Trope of like you either die
the hero you know Ariana Lala Katie
or you live long enough to become the
villain like now that we've been you
know rooting and championing them so
hard I think a lot of people are like
okay well like telling another human
being that they are nothing and they
have not a single person in this world
that cares about them like that's what
you say to someone like you know what
like it's it's a little extreme it's a
little extreme and it's dark and to all
be like rooting for this it does feel
icky and I think that it went too far
and also like these people and I said
this to you last week not on the show
but like these the people on Vanderpump
Rules like who are also like Giddy and
gleeful about like the the them going
down it's like they don't know how to
win with Grace and just like rise above
and not get on like now they're all on
the same level to me right like in the
trenches Okay cool so now you're like
just as nasty as the people that you
think you're so much better than right
and I think this conversation started
because people who don't know like the
full story or like the layers in the
history just saw like a girl being
literally told the worst things you can
tell a human being and it's like you say
that to a murderer you know you don't
say that to a girl who like obviously
what she did is horrible but like to a
girl who made a mistake no and it's not
just one mistake I don't want to like
downplay what they did because what they
did was really like
it requires a level of
scheming and lying and an intrinsic
insidiousness to lie to your best friend
for months and like it's messed up on
every single level
just she's still a person and to all for
all of us to endorse like this
pylon yeah it just like it's a little
icky and I didn't like notice it until
people started to say and I'm like yeah
there was something that just felt
too far too far and like you're the good
guys you're supposed to be the good guys
like you just don't
you'd be better off just like writing
her off and ignoring her than like yeah
getting down to their level I am so
curious like what the future holds for
Raquel
does she continue to film does she you
know kind of leave public life forever I
know her family is like really worried
about her and like doesn't want her back
on the show whatsoever and I don't think
that I think she comes from like a like
a like a money like I don't think she
needs you know this job
no I'm sure like the job is it's a big
job and it's a big paycheck and even if
her parents like might support her they
can't support her for the rest of her
life like no but like temporarily and
like live at home for a little bit but
like that's not a career but I think if
she's serious about her mental health
like
she cannot come back to the show yeah no
I I think a play to get back into the
next season and like you know to
rehabilitate Her Image then then I don't
think it is Jackie that was like not
like she's not an actor I don't think
that it is either and I don't think that
it should be and if she is in the sort
of place that's as serious as like we
think it is then I imagine that they
would be telling her like you need to
make different choices yeah yeah I don't
know how that explains like
the postcards and the letters being sent
to Tom's house from her facility like
they're still and you know that TMZ
photo we spoke about last week where he
was like on the phone with her
um because she did turn on him
yeah so what what does it mean I don't
know we'll have to wait and see I'll be
so I mean I as much as she needs to exit
reality TV like I also think she needs
to
whenever she's done with
um treatment and when she's in a good
place like maybe just sit down and like
talk about everything like with more
distance yeah
um because whatever she wants to do like
next with her life like it's still her
name that has been yep completely
definition like she's already given this
much of herself to public life like
what's what's one more interview where
she can just speak
um it will be interesting to hear what
she has to say
yeah she's just kind of the most
interesting person in this Scandal Who
has yet to speak even at the reunion she
said a whole bunch of nothing yeah no
and she just sit there and she took it
she just took it which is honestly what
else could she have done
yeah
I I did definitely an interesting
conversation and I don't know what the
right like answer is but I think people
kind of identifying like a weirdness
that they felt for this girl like is
fair yeah I think so too and I think
people like a sadness are then like
disappointed in Bravo that they would
like air that they wouldn't be able to
see that this has gone too far
you know yeah
yeah
but that's so Bravo yeah they don't like
actually take any moral stands unless
like no unless the fans yeah right right
right
very interesting very interesting uh
so we shall see what's next but now it's
time for TV recap speaking about I can't
wait to hear your thoughts on summer
house I think I have similar thoughts
um and the TV recap is brought to you by
Honey today's episode is sponsored by
PayPal honey the easy way to save money
when shopping on your iPhone or computer
did you know that it only takes a few
seconds to get honey that means before
you go to add it to your laptop or your
iPhone right now
you could be done before this ad is even
over so here's how honey Works honey is
the best thing ever I can't believe
there are people out there who don't
have honey and I just found out that you
can have it on your phone now so when
I'm always shopping I'm always like
using Apple pay it's so easy to to pay
for stuff on my phone the fact that I
can have honey on my phone now is life
changing so here's how it works you're
shopping at one of your favorite
websites you go to check out the honey
button will just appear and all you have
to do is Click apply coupons wait a few
seconds honey we'll search the internet
for any coupon it can find for that
website and if they find a working
coupon which they do most of the time
you just watch the price drop I have
saved money on literally everything I
order everything online food clothing
Electronics
make up literally everything
um so once they find a working coupon
then your price just automatically drops
it's so easy it takes a few seconds to
download a few seconds to use and you're
just saving money and people have
literally saved thousands of dollars
thanks to honey and now it doesn't just
work on desktop computers it also works
on your iPhone which is activated on
Safari on your phone and you can save on
the go getting honey seriously only
takes a few seconds by getting it you're
doing yourself a solid and when you use
our link you're supporting the toast so
get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com toast that's join honey
j-o-i-n-h-o-n-e-y.com slash t-o-a-s-t
joinhoney.com toast thanks Claude okay
so I think the big conversation and the
the the divisiveness in the seasons of
Summer houses like are Carl and Lindsay
you know being treated fairly or is this
you know something they've had coming
for years okay I can't speak about
coming for years because I haven't
watched every season of summer house I
watched last season so I know like some
of the Dynamics and I've watched
throughout the years and anytime I've
ever watched like Lindsay is just like
not for me like she's not someone same
that I could see myself like being
friends with she not because of anything
that she does just like her energy and
her personality is like not my favorite
type of girl like which is totally fine
I gravitate
totally fine totally totally fine which
is why I'm so shocked this season like I
am so team Lindsay like on uh me too
on just uh a Scruples level you know and
it's not about like who like I like and
I'm just defending like who I ride for
because obviously like I'm I love Paige
but Paige isn't really like involved
she's just like kind of a cheerleader
um because it's really Lindsay burst and
yell but the video house has taken
Danielle's side because also they just
like don't like Lindsay and Carl and I
just know and by the way my experience
with summer house is similar to yours
except for that like when it came to the
drama I always felt like what Lindsay
was doing was so wrong and I never
understood why there wasn't this like
Reckoning for Lindsay like she kind of
got away with so much and treated people
so poorly and she was always wrong and I
was like why is there not this like you
know the way they like ousted Hannah
like they they always have these like
roasts of people and Lindsay never got
that so if you would have told me that
like this is the season like everyone
held Lindsay accountable I'd be like
great but what they're holding her
accountable for they are so wrong on
they're so wrong I have know I've seen
no issue with Lindsay and Carl's
relationship if anything like all the
other relationships in the house are so
unserious and it's so funny to watch
these people try and tell Lindsey and
Carl like how their relationship should
be even like Danielle throughout the
season is trying to be like well you
guys should be fighting like first of
all Danielle and her boyfriend broke up
like two minutes later so it's just
right you know it's and even in their
relationship like they they had a very
different structure than like Lindsay
and Carl who were immediately serious
right off the bat like Danielle and
Robert moved in together for like two
months after they met each other and
then like they have a hard time seeing
each other and he works all the time and
like prioritizes that so Danielle's like
you guys should be fighting then Lindsey
and Carl got into a fight and then the
next morning they're like just acting
normal and she's like well you can't
sweep it under the rug now you have to
talk about your fight more it's like why
are you pleasing how they handle their
relationship like you aren't the moral
Authority on relationships one and two
like so they had a fight which is what
you wanted now they're not handling the
aftermath of their fight the way that
you wanted to that was the interesting
thing about out the reunion is like
we're now all involved in Lindsay and
Carl's relationship and so they're
obviously like dealing with this thing
where like Lindsay likes to drink and
and party but you know obviously Carl
struggles and like that's something
they're actively working on they said
they're in therapy and that's another
thing where it's like when Lindsay
wasn't drinking for Carl they're like
Lindsay's not big it's so weird not
being herself that she's not drinking
for Carl like that's not Lindsay then
Lindsay starts to drink again and
they're like how can Lindsay be drinking
when Carl's not drinking it's like what
can they do everything is wrong there
was such a weird element to The Reunion
where it's like they're kind of you know
talking about and analyzing things that
go on in Carl and Lindsay's relationship
that like they're fully aware of and
they're working through like what
relationship is perfect if anything like
the fact that they had fights and that
they're struggling with this like
alcohol thing like that makes it normal
and they're going to therapy and like I
just feel like the relationship is like
weirdly so healthy and everyone is doing
everything they can to be like this
relationship is toxic no their
relationship is not weirdly but it's a
serious relationship like from the
moment they decided to start dating like
they are on the path to engagement in
marriage and all the other relationships
in the house including Kyle and Amanda
because what it took them 10 years or
just like these non-serious things and
they CA they look at Carl and Lindsay
and think like they're extreme and
they're the exception when it's like no
they're just they've committed to a
different sort of relationship than the
rest of you have who are just like I
don't know [__] around for a few
years don't care like but one Lindsay
and Carl are older than them two not
only the timeline that we're talking
about like you have to remember people
it's so normal it's so normal people
used to get married after six months of
knowing each other and those
relationships have lasted 50 years they
moved in together after nine months
she's a 35 year old woman who has known
this man for seven years then three
months later they're getting engaged and
their engagement is about to be a year
and change I can't tell you a more
normal relationship with someone who
when the minute you said you wanted to
be their girlfriend you knew that you
were serious about him wanting to marry
like the way that everyone is making
them feel like they're so crazy if
Danielle says hella fast one more time
like I'm just like what is fast no
what's normal is just sitting around for
a bunch of years not sure about your
relationship while you guys all share a
bed with your friends right and you know
walk around in thongs in front of each
other's boyfriends that's more normal to
you okay wait also I think what's so
important is like the context is like
yes Lindsay and Carl are older but like
they've both in the last few years like
experienced like deep trauma and tragedy
that like that matures you you know Carl
I think you can see it like between you
know his you know entering sobriety and
then losing his brother like that [__]
changes you for life and like you become
a more serious person you understand
what's important in life Lindsay had a
miscarriage like we saw last season how
much that [__] with her and like I
think really scared her so the fact that
these two people like went through
serious things and then decided to
become serious people is literally not
shocking it's like the most normal human
reaction and I just don't understand the
hatred for their relationship and like
Danielle is so odd like her behavior and
you know what her behavior was crazy but
the fact that like everybody took her
side I think really empowered her to get
even crazier which is how we got to the
engagement oh my God I told you
yesterday nothing on reality TV shocks
me anymore just because we've been
watching it for so long everything is
just like so contrived you know like
yeah scandival shocked me but it takes a
lot Danielle's reaction to her best
friend getting engaged was the most
shocking thing I have ever seen Zach and
I were watching he doesn't really he
didn't know what he was watching he's
just been like coming in and out and he
was like what's wrong with her like if
you find out your best friend is getting
engaged to actually another one of your
best friends and you love them so much
you keep saying you would like take a
bullet for their relationship and your
instinct is to burst out in tears when
she's like sobbing the girls are holding
her like because your best friend got
engaged like I I can understand on some
level it could never be me but I'm I'm
being open-minded I understand on some
level how your two best friends are
getting engaged and you would like to
have been a part of it you know like
that he didn't reach out to you if it
was one of my best friends and
she was getting engaged and maybe he
reached out to other friends but not me
maybe I would after a few minutes of
knowing that they're getting engaged I
would be like oh I would have liked to
you know help out no by the way same but
I would never check it would never
verbalize that maybe until a few months
later if like we were drinking and I'd
say you know what like I wish I was told
like no but I would never say that I
would have like moved on from it like
but for it to be your first reaction and
your only reaction and that like the joy
that you feel for your friend who you've
been with for so many years and you've
watched her date all these losers and
breakups and everything like that that
girl is like finally getting her happily
ever after your best friend has found
joy even if it's like your the
relationship is moving hella fast for
you that your initial reaction isn't
just like
so happy
is so crazy and for it to be the
complete opposite and and the fact that
she even thinks that she should have
been involved in their engagement when
one she screamed the whole summer Carl
said he's looking at Rings she screamed
into a pillow
one hour before she found out they were
getting engaged when uh someone said
they might be getting engaged next
weekend Danielle said if they're getting
engaged next weekend I'm not coming
so that was before she even knew she
wasn't a part of the engagement and she
didn't want them to get engaged why on
God's green diddly dally Earth would
these people include you in their
engagement
no and then also this conversation like
this Witch Hunt like did Lindsay know
she was getting engaged it's fake
they're fraudulent people I want to tell
you how every girl knows they're getting
engaged like on a small level like they
know it's happening in a certain time
frame things don't just happen out of
nowhere like you have conversations
about whether you want to get married
what timeline you want to get married on
so like this Witch Hunt like if Lindsay
even knew that makes her like a
fraudulent person that's just not true
like on some level most girls know
roughly when maybe not the exact hour of
the day but the week like they they know
on some level and knowing is not this
like you know people thought like if we
could prove that Lindsay knew it would
show how fraudulent she is as a person
that's not true so that conversation was
so infuriating and so let's say she did
know so
so
I knew right and it's like if you know
you're gonna get engaged should you like
ruin the surprise just to be authentic
yes you should look ugly no yeah you
should be like are we heading to my
engagement just so that people don't
question your authenticity yeah like it
was such a suit there was just so many
conversations that were like quite
literally we got so lost in the Weeds on
those conversations at the reunion and
at the I did the day okay so let's say
she knew what does that change literally
nothing no literally that just means
that they're in an honest and open
relationship where they talk about the
future but I also wasn't even convinced
that she knew yeah she looked
extraordinarily nice for a bonfire but
she's on a reality show she was really
shocked
I think she had gotten new extensions in
general probably because she knew she
was getting engaged like soon-ish so
that kind of like made her look a little
more elevated
but I didn't care no like literally who
cares but I'm also known that she knew I
thought that her reactions I actually
was really moved by their proposal I
thought it was really sweet no Jackie
like the way I now shipped it and stand
this couple when like when I first heard
their dating I'm like oh that's weird
like I really I didn't care much but the
way they've been just like
nailed to a cross For What and by the
way I was so deeply moved during the um
conversation how Carl basically just
like an [__] told everyone that one
time Carl no no sorry Kyle told everyone
like an [__] that one time Carl
showed up to work like having done
cocaine
um which is clearly like a really
huge regret of Carl's and like something
he is probably really ashamed of and
definitely works through in his recovery
and for him to like just totally let it
go because of like what happened to him
and his brother he's like I know what
it's like to say something you so deeply
regret and I didn't get a chance to like
tell that person I was sorry I thought
was so I just really indicative of the
type of person Carl is and has become
and I'm not I'm just not going to be
thinking he's a villain because I don't
think a villain could be capable of
forgiveness like that no I don't think
he's a villain I actually made me really
want to root for Kyle and Carl's
friendship even though I don't know what
I haven't watched all the seasons so it
doesn't mean as much to me as it means
to other people but in that moment I was
like oh these two people like need to
figure it out and remain friends so also
Andy like took aside he's been doing
that like more recently it's always fun
when it's like the side that you're on
but it's really frustrating when it's
not yourself it's not he he just like
took the stance on the second part of
the reunion that like Danielle was
justified in her feelings and that
Lindsay
um was cruel in her treatment of her
which I completely disagree with and
really made like Lindsay concede to
things in order to move forward that I
don't think that she needed to concede
and that was really frustrating to watch
I'm glad that they moved forward but it
didn't feel like it was a lasting truce
because Lindsay was like apologizing for
[__] that she literally doesn't need to
be apologizing for no and Danielle's
feelings are so crazy and they were
validated all season long by everyone in
the house giving her more fuel to like
act even crazier so for Andy to do that
too like I just didn't agree with she
didn't need the a backup if anything
like Lindsay and Carl did because it was
like them against the world also not
that there's anything else that anybody
talks about on the season because
everyone's obsessed with Lindsay and
Carl but I have a few other thoughts
about the show itself sure
um if I may please I love Sam and Gabby
the first few episodes that I watched I
watched like the first four when they
aired and then I didn't watch until this
weekend and I really wasn't feeling
either of them
um just their personalities like I just
I didn't like gravitate towards but oh
my God I I'm obsessed like I'm obsessed
with salmon Corey obsessed with salmon
oh my God like I need more they're still
together now so he's obviously gonna be
on like this next season with her like
I'm just so obsessed I think they're so
cute it was really cute their first
weekend together when he came to the
house because like I guess Craig was
there or and they met and they're in the
car like getting picking up alcohol like
you're watching two people who are like
really connecting and they're having an
easy conversation and she's just you
could like see how he's just like
falling in love with her because she's
just like this bubbly really sweet
person and it was oh and by the way to
watch I completely agree I'm obsessed
with them and I like her Instagram is
all like really cute pictures of them
but that that thing that Maya said to
her like the day she walked into the
house was so mean and I thought she was
really mature about it at the reunion
she like explained how like she didn't
think Maya was coming from a bad place
but it kind of triggered any time
someone has said that to her who was
coming from a bad place I thought it was
so [__] mean because I'm like that
too like I relate to Sam in the way
they're like we're a lot and more like
loud and it's not for everyone but like
to be pulled aside like the day you get
to a house full of new people just being
told to basically shut the [__] up it
wasn't the first day but it was um it
was early Still Still rude it was so
rude yeah
I guess but it's like if everyone's
talking about it behind her back
what's the right thing to do
but she didn't say everyone's saying
this about you she said you do like
factually you talk too much
mean like it's okay let's say she does
talk too much
is okay so like it's not like she you
know kills people too much like it's
just her personality yeah it was it was
weird to watch and now there is this
weird dynamic and it's interesting that
this season like the new girls
gravitated towards Lindsay whereas they
usually gravitate towards Paige and the
bed crew and I always thought like in
past Seasons like that's such a plus in
Paige and Amanda's column it's like
they're always so welcoming and I think
it really showed how like kind of toxic
Lindsay and Danielle's friendship was
like they wouldn't let anyone in they
made no space for anyone else like it
was rude and it was really hard to be
and I thought Paige articulated that so
well how she was like I was here you
know as a new girl once and like you
guys were horrible to me and that's why
she's made a conscious effort always to
like be in the bed with Maya and be in
the bed with Sierra and like always
welcome in the new girls
um so I did think it was interesting
that the new girls immediately were on
the other side of the couch
and even throughout the season like when
Sam was like I'm so happy about
Lindsay's engagement but I think I'll
just like be happy over here because I
don't want to like upset everyone it was
like no one all season like Lindsay
didn't have beef really with anyone
other than Danielle outwardly but like
anytime something negative happened for
Lindsay or like there was a fight or a
conversation like everyone was like a
little gleeful about it and it's like
I can understand like they're also human
beings and I can also understand maybe
Lindsay is like an annoying [__]
person and so when when other people are
like seeing that too you're like yeah
she's annoying but when you're watching
it as a viewer it just like comes off
really mean when everybody is treating
one person that way yep especially a
person who's like obviously shown a lot
of growth
like that's okay I do believe when they
were talking about [__] that happened in
the past like you know the Dumont like I
do believe Lindsay has probably her fair
share of
bad moments in the last few years but
like
to bring it up now when they're so
clearly in a different place and have
been through so much like it just feels
irrelevant no and it's like if we're
moving forward then we cannot keep
bringing up
stuff if we've like said that we're
moving on from it like to me that final
conversation between Danielle and
Lindsay that Lindsay was so terrible at
like how is she terrible first of all
she didn't say anything she literally
didn't say anything that was like
everyone's problem Danielle called her a
monster Danielle said the friendship was
over Danielle was like losing her mind
and everyone was like the way Lindsay
treated you in that conversation I'm
like Lindsay just like responded like
yes or no no and Lindsay was just like
Fed Up Like This is a person who's like
kind of crazy like you really can't
argue with them so much and I felt like
she was just like I don't need this
friendship anymore so it's like not
worth fighting for so yeah maybe she
came off a little cold but like it's
[__] exhausting to argue with someone
who's like so deeply unwell deeply
unwell in all season Danielle's like I
would take a bullet for you it's like
you would take a bullet for me but you
couldn't be happy that I'm getting
engaged to the love of my life why buy
the bullet what I don't need a bullet I
just would want you to be genuinely
happy for me yeah but she's like really
not asking a lot or at least fake it
fake it I don't care yeah and also then
the girls were trying to say that like
Lindsey was managing out for becoming
friends with like you know the bed crew
right but I don't think it was that like
I think it's like when you're best
friends with someone and since they all
have to be in a house together yeah like
she can go and be friends with other
people but like if you start talking
badly about me to people who do not like
me
I cannot be friends with you
yeah that's how I feel like that's how I
feel too yep like you'll be friends with
them like go talk about all you like fun
stuff whatever but if you want to talk
about me with my enemies we can't be
friends
I completely agree and I don't think
that that's crazy
me neither so I use fully team Lindsay
and I just needed to get that off my
chest because I was so surprised that I
was so alone
well I'm so glad Sam and Gabby had my
back too
yeah I but you know what that
conversation about Gabby was interesting
because I did feel like when she first
got there like she wasn't really being
genuine she was like trying to like have
moments and be funny and I understood
why like Maya and Sierra were like we
felt like we would have had like an
instant connection with you and like
you're just kind of like surface level
like I actually get that but I think
after that they like totally wrote her
off and she was probably like nervous
like it's so weird it's such a weird
thing to like be in a house with all
these cameras like she was just like
trying a little too hard in the
beginning and like then everyone
completely wrote her off that by the
time she got comfortable like they
weren't even open to being her friend
yeah that's how I felt as a viewer but
like uh when she finally was just like
being herself and like just having like
cute real moments I was like oh I really
like her and I felt that same way about
Sam like At first I felt like she was
trying too hard I didn't understand her
and it just took a little time but like
I think they're both like really cute
sweet girls
same
um all right so that'll be interesting
to see like who goes to the wedding and
like you know I'm happy for Lindsay and
Carl honestly like weirdly I ship
weirdly I ship they should have made
everyone
yeah
just because like if they don't everyone
will hold it over them for the next 30
Years
definitely
but they said that they would do another
summer in the house so I'm curious who
will be
who will be in the house again well the
thing is like they obviously need Corey
they need more guys oh my God I don't
even know that guy's name Alex Chris
sure
um like they need more guys it's great
that Corey's in a relationship they need
more single guys and I don't know if
there's actually like a lot of girls I
feel like two of them need to go yeah
yeah I think Paige will come back
because also like Bravo loves Paige
Craig Paige is a fan favorite corn Craig
are literally perfect for each other I
think they add like an interesting
dynamic because they're like a serious
couple but they're like somewhere
between Kyle and Amanda and Lindsay and
Carl like they're taking it slow but
they're serious in the last few episodes
they had some interesting conversations
about their relationship that were very
surprising to me in like I mean
obviously the big question is like when
are they gonna move in together and
where are they going to live because
they're still doing long distance but
um they also just like like each other
so much that they don't want to like
ruin the relationship by doing something
that like neither of them are ready for
and weirdly long distance like really
works for them they both have like very
flexible lives they spend a lot of time
together yeah but they have to take the
next step if they want to take the next
in the next step which is like you know
marriage and kids but they have to like
they were like we know we want to get
married and have kids and raise them in
Charleston but how do we get to that to
that point like because you know next we
need to move in together but like where
do we move in Paige does not want to
move to Charleston right now and I don't
think that she should have to
yeah I feel like honestly if I was gonna
cut someone it would probably be Maya
mostly because like she actually had a
lot going on this summer like her
boyfriend cheated on her and there was
like so much that went down that she
refused to put on air like she didn't
talk about she made him take his mic off
yeah like she she's not open to sharing
and that's I totally respect but like
you can't really be on a reality show
where people are like literally out here
bleeding out I mean
miscarriage like that no one called her
out for that when like literally
Carl and Lindsay tried like didn't talk
about a fight the morning after they had
a fight the night before on camera and
that was you know obfuscating their
relationship when my literally pulled
Oliver into the bathroom told him to
take his mic off so they could talk
about the fact that he had cheated on
her they were pretty much broken up but
that he was coming to the party that
weekend just like round out the summer
so they didn't have to deal with the
breakup on camera
right no she was like producing her post
yeah right and like she got no Flack for
it but like a person like that is really
not necessary on a show where there are
so many girls already and the girls are
you know they're doing the most yeah and
honestly the bed situation this season
really was starting to stress me out
there was a lot of bed sharing there was
a lot of of slob like
bedrooms like it was getting really bad
towards the end like I think I'd rather
have like a more trimmed down cast with
everyone contributing than like you know
four people Willy Wonka in a bed all
weekend
yeah but I actually think like a lot of
people were like this season of summer
house is bad I actually think it turned
out really good and people were like I
don't understand this group of people I
agree with that but I do think there's
actually like a lot of potential for
where we go from here you know now
knowing that we have like Corey and Sam
like I do think there is a world is best
friends with Craig right no and they
need to bring like another cute
Charleston boy who's single like they
actually there's a lot of potential for
this group when the season first started
people were like what the [__] is going
on and I agreed but I actually think
there's you know it could work yeah I
think that it could work too and I just
was curious what was going on with the
bedroom sorry I just you know you know
me yeah I can't get over the logistics
because in the downstairs master bedroom
this season there's two King beds and it
felt like nobody wanted to sleep there
like there were some some nights where
someone would sleep in one of those beds
alone I feel like maybe the AC wasn't
working down there
also upstairs like everyone was running
fans 24 7. I feel like the AC in the
house was broken this year I'm just
saying well like a lot of the bedrooms
were like altered this year like they
put up walls they removed walls like
honestly that double master was [__]
weird yeah no it was really weird it was
giving like uh um like are you the one
where they all sleep like on beds in the
middle of the room together
but this was the first season where like
Kyle and Amanda didn't just like
automatically get the best room in the
house and I've always like felt like
that wasn't fair like yeah you're two
people yeah they did but everyone is two
people they got through the queen bed no
they have a king bed from the looks of
it they got the biggest one bed the
biggest room that has one bed and a
bathroom right right right right but I
agree because now Lindsay and Carl are
engaged they deserve a nice room too
they have an Sam
Cory and Sam Paige and Craig but Paige
like doesn't like her privacy
yeah she likes to be with the girl is
yeah she even there was one time Craig
visited where he stayed in a room with
her Maya and Sierra and and they were
they were like literally full-size beds
that they pushed together the four of
them slept in a bed pushed together oh I
miss that yeah no that was when things
got shocking for me I was like summer
needs to end yeah no summer has taken a
toll it's time to go back to the city
could you imagine I can't like imagine
anything more uncomfortable to me
yeah but you're just not like that by
the way yeah no I'm crazy you don't even
like to share a bed with me like when we
travel for work we get two hotel rooms
it's the craziest thing I know but I
feel like now if we if we traveled for
work we would get one
closer now yeah no it's also like
financially more responsible
yeah
but it is but it's like on the one hand
you would think I would want no by the
way
we do it when like when like a brand or
like a network has paid for our hotel
rooms like okay yeah we'll take two but
if we're paying for it ourselves we'll
share
no he never shared that's not even true
like remember when we went to uh when we
stayed at the Mondrian we were just
talking about this yeah we got two rooms
and they were like both so big it was so
stupid but we were also like coming back
to coach where we just shared a house
and like you just need to depress at
least
um see I'm more of like a page in that
sense like I don't mind like you know
sleeping with other people
yeah but now I do think it would be
weird if we got two separate rooms now
that I'm thinking about it
but I feel like I'm also just like now
that I'm a mom just used to having like
chaos around me all the time where it's
like I used to like just like really
like like
like a sanctuary yeah and now it's just
like that's all gone to hell 100
um well this was our longest show today
and I think it's time we wrap it up so
thanks so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please if you're subscribing
this video thumbs up also I love us and
we're podcasting me down to our Spotify
Channel I already guessed all the places
to review about how beautiful stunning
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing day tomorrow we are
in studio with satchelor Satchel oh my
God I gotta get my questions ready for
her for you to ask her and it's gonna be
great you don't want to miss it we love
you dearly the reason why we went so
long today is because we don't have to
worry about the Kurds I know because
we're recording from home we don't have
memory cards so that's one small perk of
Audio Only yeah love ya bye